foreigners matchmaking definitely need
to rework besides the fact that you get
disconnected about one other two games
that you play
it's the matchmaking with the players
that bothers me the most
whenever you get into a game there's
about an 80% chance that somebody with
champion status on is going to either
have a gear rating of 80 or higher
you'll have like your team stacked full
of like you know rep 1 everyone else is
under rep 1 and then the enemy team has
everyone over rep 3 with a hundred and
eight gear score now does the gear score
really matter it could to an extent if
it's a gear rank like 108 versus a
starting player but other than that it
kinda doesn't matter I mean if you're
like a if you're like a 100 versus a 108
it's more based on the character because
you're almost the same but other than
that accounting doesn't matter as much
there's plenty of videos out there
explaining us the gear and if the gear
stats and ranks and upgrades even
matters then you can check those out for
yourself what I want to talk about
though is that why are we getting paired
up with them if you're a new player your
ideal idea is to pick a character or
pick many characters let's say you pick
like three it'll be like Ken say orochy
and then we'll do Raider and you pick
that you pick those three and you go I
like Orochi more so I'm going to start
using him a lot more that's your main
character that's your job is like a new
player you find out what you well you
who you want to play it if you're from
the beta then it's a bit different you
probably already have your character
already known like I started the beta
with Ken say and I kept him throughout
the whole whole game that's the but this
is a problem though with this weird
matchmaking the way that it gives you
these players I can't tell if it's
random or if I just that [ __ ] look I
keep getting paired up when I you shoe
goofy I'm a level six but you go Dino
gear score with them whatsoever
that's why I want to test them out and I
keep getting paired up with people that
have gear ranks of 80 and 9
now to be fair I do play with a friend
but he has only a gear score of like 15
and he's not even rough one yet yet
we're still getting paired up with the
108 rough six and gear score player why
though if you're a new player and you
get paired up with this person and
you're getting your ass beat
once [ __ ] would you want to play the
game work it's drawing people away from
this game and that's not what Ubisoft
should want if they want to keep this
game going they need something to figure
it out now to be fair people have come
up with ideas where instead of playing
with a new character you should play a
shits on a boss or you play like a duel
or brawl but that eventually gets boring
and then a plus of your favorite game
mode is like Dominion or elimination so
then you're not going to have fun
playing game modes that you don't enjoy
me personally I'm not a big fan of duel
even though it's a big part of this game
not a very big fan of it but I'm played
as often and so I stick to elimination
and does match them such it's just these
little things that Ubisoft needs to
understand that is like it's breaking
their game it's making people return
this game and sell it and then not play
and that's not what people want it's not
what nope nobody wants that because
because the more this continues on on
top of the error connection every two
games this is going to kill this game
within a few months it's not going to
last this long
Ubisoft needs to figure out what to do
or something now if you are a new player
like I said before you would try it out
a bunch of bots or stick it through and
hopefully you won't get a level 108 but
if you do don't be really mad they're
probably beat your ass but kind of a
point that's why there's that high so
don't be too mad if they come up and
just absolutely wreck your [ __ ] play a
bunch of dual brawl with a friend or go
up against the bots to just rank up your
character and find out if they're good
or not
that'd be the end of the video guys hope
you did enjoy this little quick talk
about skill based matchmaking and should
it be implemented and such and such well
if you guys did enjoy it like this video
though if you want more of these more of
these types of video
is who movie subscribe it really does
help me out and knows that you guys are
interested and other than that I will
see you all later and peace out